the Nisbet families packing up like
thousands of other expatriates Matt and
his wife summer can't be persuaded to
remain
Matt was born in Hong Kong and met his
wife here 16 years ago they're typical
of the white-collar professionals now
taking their skills elsewhere in their
case Australia where Summer's from
the honest truth is I don't think
there's anything that would keep me here
right now
with their three children they live in
the other Hong Kong lantau Island Hong
Kong's biggest and far from the
congestion and clamor of the central
business district
many factors are behind the decision to
go including changes to the school
curriculum with a focus on patriotic
education I think it just made the
decision to go easier and easier we've
had such a blessed time here in Hong
Kong the children have thrived my
husband and I have had successful
careers and it's been a very comfortable
place to live for a long time but
there's a real sense that the future is
going to be different to the past and
we've thought about that deeply and I'd
say yes it's contributed
Hong Kong's always been a transitory
place
25 years ago I reported on another
Exodus
[Music]
retiring British civil servants and
others who'd enjoyed a life of privilege
here headed home in style unwilling to
live under Chinese rule after the
Handover
[Applause]
now it's happening again
many of the Hong Kong Chinese leaving
are going to Britain taking advantage of
a new Visa scheme that opens a pathway
to citizenship
a quarter of a century on Hong Kong's
population of around seven and a half
million is decreasing more than 300 000
people have left since the
implementation of that National Security
Law almost two years ago and one recent
opinion poll shows that around a quarter
of this City's population have made
plans to leave one reason for that is
Hong Kong's strict covid-19 regulations
that earlier this year saw mothers
separated from children
another impetus is politics especially
the new National Security Law
sped family soon won't need to worry
about all of that like most of those
going they'd rather be staying
if only circumstances were different
Adrian Brown Al Jazeera Hong Kong